tenemos que x está definida como el
logaritmo de 3x para 0 menor que x menor
que 3 y por otra parte 4x por el
logaritmo de 9 cuando x es mayor o igual
a 3
así que basándonos en esta definición
deje de x queremos encontrar el límite
cuando extiende a 3 de x observa que
este 3 está justo en medio entre estos
dos casos vamos al primer caso donde x
está entre 0 y 3 cuando es mayor que
será menor que 3 y luego vamos a ver el
otro caso donde tocamos a 3 en el y para
encontrar el límite queremos encontrar
el límite del lado izquierdo así que
estaremos trabajando con este caso con
el caso de arriba ya que si tenemos a x
menor que 3 entonces estamos en este
caso pero también queremos encontrar el
límite del lado derecho lo cual nos
pondría en el segundo caso y si ambos
límites existen y son iguales entonces
ese valor va a ser el límite que
buscamos
vamos a hacerlo permíteme primero ir por
el lado izquierdo entonces me voy a
tomar el límite cuando existente a 3 con
valores menores que 3 así que nos vamos
a aproximar por la izquierda de heather
x bueno esto es equivalente a decir que
queremos encontrar el límite cuando x
tiende a 3 - cuando x es menor que 3 nos
estamos aproximando a 3 por la izquierda
y entonces estamos en este caso de aquí
así que vamos a estar operando con este
pedazo eso es lo que es gd x cuando x es
menor que 3
entonces me quedaría el logaritmo de 3x
y ya que esta función de aquí está
definida y es continua sobre el
intervalo que nos interesa ya que es
continua para todas las x mayores que 0
entonces podemos simplemente sustituir 3
aquí y ver a qué se estaría aproximando
entonces esto sería igual a el logaritmo
de 3 por 3 o el logaritmo del 9 y bueno
recuerda cuando se escribe simplemente
loco sin escribir la base es implícito
que aquí la base es 10 entonces tenemos
el logaritmo
10 el logaritmo en base ty es el
logaritmo en base 10 el logaritmo en
base 10 y lo menciono porque es algo
importante de saber y que a veces no
éramos bien ahora vamos a plantear el
otro caso vamos a plantear la situación
donde nos aproximamos a 3 por el lado
derecho por los valores mayores que 3 y
por lo tanto ahora vamos a estar en este
escenario de aquí entonces esto va a ser
igual al límite cuando extiende a 3 por
la derecha deje de x en este caso cuando
x es mayor que 3 y entonces me quedaría
4 - x por el logaritmo de 9 y al
principio esto parece algún tipo de
expresión logarítmica hasta que te das
cuenta de que el logaritmo entre 9 es
una constante lugar y que en base 19 va
a ser algún número cercano a 1 y esta
expresión en realidad definiría una
recta para x mayor o igual a 3 que x es
sólo una recta aunque parezca un poco
más complicada y de hecho esto estará
definido para todos los números reales y
además es continuo para cualquier x que
pongas adentro así que para encontrar
este límite
a qué se va a aproximar esta expresión
mientras nos aproximamos a tres en la
dirección positiva bien podemos
simplemente evaluarla en tres donde me
quedarían cuatro menos tres por el
logaritmo de nueve lo cual es uno por el
logaritmo de nueve entonces todo esto es
simplemente el logaritmo en base 10 de 9
y ya está
observa que el límite por la izquierda
es igual al límite por la derecha ambos
son el logaritmo de 9 así que la
respuesta aquí es logaritmo de 9 y hemos
terminado